Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Suleyman Cengiz
Şimdi hep hayalden konuştuk ya,
benim de çocukluğumdan beri,
dünyayı gezme hayallerim vardı.
Ama gerçekleşeceğini
hiç tahmin etmiyordum.
Gezdik, bayağı bir güzel yerler gördük.
Ama burada benim tek gayem;
insanları çok seviyorum,
yargılamadan, ötekileştirmeden,
değiştirmeye uğraşmadan.
"İnsanlarla nasıl verimli
bir diyalog kurabilirim?
İnsanlarla nasıl bir duygu paylaşımı,
fikir paylaşımı yapabilirim?"
Bunlar vardı.
Çocuklar evlendikten sonra,
dört duvar arasında oturmak
bana çok ters geldi.
Kendimle baş başa kalıp
bazı hatalarımda kendimi yargılama,
kendimi suçlama başlıyor.
Baktım, ben kendi kendime
en çok zarar veren kendim oluyorum.
Ne yapabilirim?
İnsanlarla bir diyalogda
olayım, görüşeyim,
bir şey vereyim, bir şey alayım,
bir şeyler paylaşalım.
Çok şeyler paylaştıkça
mutlu olduğumu fark ettim.
Bu mutlulukla başka birilerine de
mutlu etme ihtiyacını hissettim.
Arkadaşlar sayesinde, işte böyle
diyaloglarım, çevrem çok geniş,
onlar seviyorlar, sağ olsunlar,
ben de onları çok seviyorum.
Ve böyle diyaloglar giderken,
çok yerler gezdim.
Tabii ben kendim normal bir vatandaş
olarak, ne yaptığımın farkında değilmişim.
Baktım, bayağı bir şeyler başarmışız.
İnsanlarla, işte diyorum ya,
diyalog kurmak ötekileştirmeden
sevmek ve bu sevgiyi de
hiçbir çıkar yol gözetmeden kurmak,
değiştirmeye uğraşmadan.
Mutlu olduğumu bir hayat
olarak yaşamak değil de,
hayatla dans edebilmeyi öğrenmek
çok güzel geldi bana.
(Alkış)
Teşekkürler.
Şimdi bizim Türkiyemizde,
ülkemizde bir kalıplaşma var.
Anneanneler, babaanneler torun bakar,
evinde oturur, köşesine çekilir.
Bir de geçmiş neslimizin, anne ve babanın
ve bir de bizim çocukların
bir kalıplaşmış şeye uymamızın
mecburiyeti gibi görüyorlar.
E ben buna uymamışım,
asi bir yapım var herhâlde.
(Kahkaha)
(Alkış)
Ya benim bu pozisyonum,
insanlara çok değişik geliyor;
çok değişik eleştiriler alıyorum.
Ama bu eleştirilerden kendimi, nasıl
yararlandırabilirim onu bir öğrendim.
Barışık yaşamayı öğrendim.
Çünkü eleştirinin bir getirileri var.
Yani tartabiliyorsun,
hatalarını görebiliyorsun.
Bazı insanlardan mesela, geliyorlar bana.
Çünkü gezginci bir insanın,
sırtında çanta,
yırtık blue jean, saçı uzun, kulağı
küpeli, kirli sakallı birisi gezer.
Ya böyle bir teyze gezemez.
Ay geliyorlar bana, böyle
suratını da değiştiriyor,
bu teyze mi gezmiş, diyorlar.
(Kahkaha)
Hoşuma gidiyor.
Yani,
(Kahkaha)
(Alkış)
Ya insanlara işte yargılamadan baktığında,
her şey insana tamamlayıcı oluyor.
Bir insanı insan olarak;
dini, dili, fikri, siyasi görüşü
ne olduğu hiç önemli değil,
benim için bir insan insansa o yeter.
(Alkış)
Çünkü insanın kendine ait bir,
özel fikirleri, değerleri var.
Onu değiştirmeye kalktığında, en yakın
ailenden olsun, komşundan olsun,
tanımadığın bir insandan olsun,
çünkü o da benim özelime giriyor,
o da beni değiştirmeye uğraşmaya kalkıyor.
Ne oluyor, savaşlar çıkıyor.
Ailede başlayan savaşlar,
işte dünyaya da yayılmış.
Hep çıkar savaşları.
İnsanlar, işte diyorum ya,
kendi özelini ve karşının özeline
dokunmadan ve dokundurtmadan,
insanlarla diyalog kurmak
çok güzel bir şey.
İnsanı sevince her zorluk aşılıyor.
Kendi odak noktanda,
kendi değer yargılarınla
boğuşmamayı öğretiyor insana.
İnsan kendi hayatına şeffaf
baktıkça, karşıya da bakıyor.
Bu, karşının da şeffaf değer yargılarını
önemseyerek baktıysan,
hani diyaloglar da güzelleşiyor,
samimiyetler çoğalıyor,
insanın da değerleri çoğalıyor.
Yani kimseye beklentim olmadan,
bir şey beklemeden ve kendi hayatımın
kontrolünün bende olması,
çok güzel bir şey.
Allah herkese nasip etsin.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkış)